now for some analysis on our top stories
let's bring in senior political analyst
Brit Hume good evening Bret I want to
start with impeachment and where we
stand tonight
you know this as time goes on and we go
into a Christmas break and break in for
the new year do you think more time
helps Democrats make that case for more
witnesses and documents in the Senate
trial well I'm not sure that this
current week we're in this holiday week
through the new year will make much
difference but everything we're seeing
from from Senator Schumer and and
speaker Pelosi suggests that they're in
real doubt as to whether the evidence
that they brought to brought forth so
far is good enough and that they are
very very urgently seeking a way to
hopefully on from their perspective find
some more evidence that's what this
whole issue about about trying to bring
in witnesses though they're having there
certainly weren't any witnesses in the
Clinton impeachment that seems to be all
about McConnell leader McConnell in the
Senate meanwhile he's quite comfortable
with the current situation he doesn't
seem to be in any hurry just start at
trial and speaker Pelosi doesn't see how
much leverage our view and the
Constitution doesn't give her any and
the only way to make this work I suppose
is to mount some sort of public pressure
to to demand witnesses but McConnell has
the votes he can run this trial anyway
wants to you know Britt do you get the
sense that not only on the Ukraine issue
but now with this new talk about
possibly looking back at the Muller
report and the documents that the house
is trying to get from the Muller
investigation that Democrats are trying
to find something even with more time to
maybe even stick that into an
impeachment article well that's what it
sounds like
all of it adds up to the same thing no
Bret doesn't it it adds up to the idea
that whatever they have isn't enough and
they've so far uh turley failed to move
a single Republican vote either in the
house or the Senate that we at least
that we know of no senator has come
forward to say that that he or she is in
fair
voting to convict the president it's a
very high bar of course requiring
two-thirds of the Senate there's no
indication that it's gonna get anywhere
near that and I'd i seriously doubt
brett that if they were to whomp up some
further charges based upon the Muller
report which largely exonerated the
president it did raise some obstruction
of justice issues but even those were
not sufficient to get Muller to even say
that there'd been an obstruction of
justice only that there were cases that
might have added up to that and of
course that was rejected by rod
Rosenstein and of course Attorney
General bar so you know I think that
what the Democrats are dealing with here
is an extreme long shot and maybe two
long shots but yeah as we get to the end
of the year I mean the president seems
like he has some political wind at his
back despite this impeachment he's got a
couple of pull he's 50 percent some some
about 45 46 but the economy is churning
on all cylinders
yeah and that's normally the most
critical issue is there certainly what's
given him bullying so far you know
during this past year there were times
when there was a lot of talk about the
possibility we might be looking at the
onset of a recession sometime soon
sometime perhaps even before the 2020
election now nobody seems to be saying
that which you know if you're an
investor you might think that oh that's
a bad sign when when nobody's worried
but but from a political standpoint the
president would appear to be in better
shape than he was at the beginning of
the year which is hardly what his
adversaries in the Democratic Party had
a hope for when they were you know in
the process of trying to impeach him
that's the way that matter stands at
least for now as I see it
last thing bread do you expect Nancy
Pelosi to move these articles soon after
we get back from this break January 6 7
I mean that that standoff is gonna stop
well I would think so because I think
she made a stab here and trying to
figure a way to get some more evidence
into the case and if that fails if she
just leaves the leaves the leaves the
articles in the house never moved into
the Senate the whole thing kind of dies
alternatively perhaps McConnell would
have the option
of making a motion - in the senator - to
dismiss the case for lack of prosecution
so he's got some he's got some choices
I'm not sure she has very many left
beretta as always thank you and Merry
Christmas
you bet that's a beaut